Ruby too hey Margo I am dying I'm
suspense what did your mom say well I
chickened out last night but I'm going
to ask her now right now this second did
you do the confidence building exercise
I got you I did something even better
[Music]
oh hey Junior Prom is the sacred right
of every human teenager as a kraken who
is barely pulling off this whole human
thing I need to be there so that I can
blend in and as a proudmathly I know
that to find a potential solution I have
to evaluate the problem now I know the
rules our family is not allowed in the
ocean ever for any reason and I love
rules I do I really
but the prom vote is on the water not in
the water what if there's a storm you
might ask well I've analyzed weather
trend data and my trusty friend the
internet
assured me that it will be smooth
sailing on prom night and lastly this is
the captain of said promote look into
those eyes tell me he hasn't seen it all
lost him with my life and so should you
and that is why I Ruby Gilman should go
to prom thank you
strong presentation I like the energy
but still a no
evidence science internet trust me Ruby
I know what's best for you and what's
best is to always stay on land that's
why we moved here it's much safer for us
sorry tadpole Mom's right damn breakfast
hey didn't you say that prom was a post
Malone Colonial patriarchal construct it
is but we would go as a group as a form
of protest wow so brave what do you
think I had these printed for my big
launch party I think I'm in love
you still need me to be there yes this
is a make or break moment I'm selling an
entire development but Mom you're Agatha
Gilman and I slay the competition he got
us our dream home and I'm not asking how
well I just want to show potential
buyers what a happy Oceanside family
looks like I'll be closing my shop for
the day so I can man the grill from
chill man to grill man oh Arthur you
should think about hiring someone to
help you business has been booming since
you started bottled up hey there welcome
back to bottled up now let's hoist those
sales
Magic
wow you two are quite the power couple
you think that's great you're looking at
The Undefeated dodgeball champ
he's a legend yeah yeah you guys are all
crushing it Ruby don't sell yourself
short you're amazing at math I am the
reason Conor's passing algebra oh Connor
so dreams
you each landed one marine biologist
quarterly oh Ruby you're still reading
this trash humans don't know everything
about the ocean mom there's a whole
world down there that I have never seen
jellyfish Plankton coral reefs but what
else lives there I know monsters and
those monsters want to hurt Krakens like
us this is where we belong Oceanside is
our home then help me fit in by letting
me go to prom
answer is no
time to go ah mom human dishes to Gilman
fade away at the buzzer and good Lim up
everyone let's all have a very human day
does it bother you guys that we lie to
everyone all the time oh we're not lying
we're just omitting yeah okay I remember
anyone else we are from Canada
[Music]
foreign
just kidding not guilty totally normal
she blew I'm from Canada
a
[Music]
oh that totally makes sense I've got my
eye on you Gilpin girl and my other eye
too
our tour begins we're 15 years ago I
swear I saw the monsters
hey guys good reading no how did it go
yes I'm dying to find out babe I've been
stress gaming well it's official mom
won't let me go to prom and I know it's
not what we wanted but we still have
plan B our very cool anti-palm party and
what is the most liberated food out
there guys I'm talking fondue
Ruby um
no I'm just gonna come right out and say
it Kayla asked me to the prom oh and uh
I said call my damn AKA I said yes what
I said yeah oh I got that loud and clear
okay Margo has toward our hearts into a
million tiny pieces and that's fine more
fondue for the rest of us right guys
yeah uh once Margot was going with Kayla
Trevin said oh well should we just go
together and I agreed so Trevin and I
are going to the prom together as
friends huh yeah only his friends what
what I'm sorry Ruby we promise always
stick together does Squad solidarity
mean nothing to you well of course it
does which is why you should come with
us you'll be on a boat you'll be
completely safe unless there's a tragic
accident Bliss no catastrophizing sorry
you guys know my mom and that is why we
made Plan B Margo just bring Kayla to
our anti-prom party we will watch back
movies we'll dip Swiss enough with the
fondue we eat a lot of cheese wheels of
it think about how many events we've
missed in Squad solidarity because if
your mom's irrational anti-ocean rule I
guess a few what there was as the field
trip to the Submarine Museum the school
Beach day all County Surf Contest the
Oceanside Festival of the bar my
grandmother's Beach birthday party
Kayla's Beach birthday happy birthday
birthday party publishes you're always
welcome at the graveyard but this isn't
just any party this is prom and I really
want to be a part of it we
all do yeah no I get it you guys should
go without me it's one thing for my mom
to ruin my life she doesn't have to ruin
yours uh what if
your mom doesn't have to know deception
I'm on board come on Ruby do it do it I
want to but if my mom finds out oh life
is not a dress rehearsal it's time for
you to go big and go to from okay okay
okay okay
you're right
okay I'll do it
look at a prom yeah
and I'm gonna ask Connor Connor okay
that's a that's a big swing there but we
are here for it step one you're going to
need a promposal blue sky with me people
any ideas maybe I can ask him with
something epic like an advanced
quadratic equation and when I solve it
the answer is
prom